this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show and it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about life i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague fellow
ramsey personality george camel the
phone number to jump in to talk to
george and i today is triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five but
let's just call the elephant out in the
studio shall we george what's that if
you if you were hoping dave was on today
dave ramsey he's the legend he's the
icon he's not but you and i are it's a
good call so george is here he's a money
expert he's living the plan uh about
ready to complete baby step seven and
george is fantastic he'll answer your
money questions today and then i uh am
focused on helping you get a bigger
shovel how about that
that's a good one uh how about enjoying
lifting the shovel
so what we're talking about here is is
doing work
that you really enjoy but also making
really good money how about impact and
income metaphorical money and meeting
that's right but george i i want to talk
about something because we you know i've
got this new book coming out as you know
november night from paycheck to purpose
and there's a lot of people even on my
facebook page for the ken coleman show
they're going well i can't buy the book
this month it's not in the budget wow
what say you to people who are going i
can i i would love to have the dream job
i would love to make more money but i'm
i'm gazelle intense right now you know
my seven stages you know the baby steps
it can be done yes i feel like i lived
the stages before i knew them and you
were one of my mentors along the way in
my career journey so i can help these
people get a raise oh yeah get out of
the baby steps faster so we'll talk
about some work questions you got a
toxic boss maybe doing some some stuff
like that you're going hey i got a
couple options ken which way should i go
i have no clue what i want to do ken i'm
interested we'll take some of those
questions as well as the money questions
and by the way george has lived it uh
george and i've been french for we were
talking about the other day a decade
coming up on a decade yeah and by the
way the very same path
uh except different lanes money and then
purpose and peak performance on my side
but we have very similar stories and we
love being together always fun to be
with you george you ready to do this i'm
so ready ken all right let's do it let's
get to the phones the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five dylan joins us in
lancaster pennsylvania dylan how can we
help
hey i had a question about renting um
and whether i should wait or what
okay give us a few more details
so i'm looking
apartments around here are all around 14
to 1500 some a little more some a little
less
and uh
i found a place that is really nice that
i i would really like to give it to for
1400
um
well i worked out a budget and i'd be
i'd be able to swing it with utilities
and
everything else as far as car insurance
and all that
but i'd only be
like they only make 300 400 at the end
of each month
so that's you're saying the wiggle room
you'd have three to four hundred dollars
left yeah
yeah that's so how what's your
what's your take-home pay every month
uh around
35 to 3600.
okay i mean this is a that's a big chunk
of your income going to rent
yeah are you are you single
uh single getting married oh okay so i
want to know your wife to be is she
employed and if she is what is she going
to be bringing to this household income
um
she's in school right now she went set
free good um and should we should we
coming out probably
for dairy management for around
probably 40 000 a year okay
all right yeah i mean i like the idea of
her income being a part of this equation
because that makes this thing make a lot
more sense but right now if i'm you
you're getting a roommate until you are
hitched and she moves in george george
call on me i'm raising my hand ken ken
right here thank you very much dylan i
did this
uh i did this exact thing uh when stacy
and i got married nearly 24 years ago i
was working in richmond virginia and she
was in charlotte north carolina getting
ready for the wedding i was in my first
job working for the governor and i did
this same deal i got an apartment for us
for six months because i started my job
in january it was almost six months to
the day
um uh when we would be getting married
and so i had a buddy who was in richmond
in that political circle and i got him
to sign on for six months and he covered
half of the rent for six months moved
out uh while we were on the honeymoon so
this can be done george i just i i thank
you for calling on me today that was i
just i like that moment it was great so
dylan are you opposed to getting a
roommate question
oh i'm not opposed to it
but here's where i was thinking if if um
would you guys think it's smart i'm
going to be getting a raise in january
to about it'd be about five grand a
month is what my income would go up to
that's a big race would it be smart
would i have to jump one like so to get
this apartment i'd have to jump on it
soon do you think it'd be smart to put
to kind of put the cart before the horse
and do it even though i don't have the
rage yet or should i wait till i get the
raise then be looking at something
i mean i'm i'm telling you you can rent
that apartment right now but you've got
to get a roommate day one
okay and how far away is this wedding
don't count on
oh it's in june
in june you know what okay i mean if
you're if you're bringing home 5 000 a
month we're talking you're probably
you're going to be making what 80k
85k yeah it'd be it'd be around there i
didn't see the math but yeah doing math
is important here because here's what i
want i want this parameter to to fit
into your life where your rent is no
more than about a quarter of your
take-home pay so that's the math i'm
doing to go all right fourteen hundred
dollars a month you've gotta make a
little over five grand to fit within
that parameter
so if that's the case yes you can rent
on your own because you have a lot of
margin left over in your budget to
continue on with the baby steps do you
have debt right now
i do it's about
nine thousand
nine thousand what kind of debt is that
it's just a car loan i took out a car
one before i started listening to you
guys okay yeah if i'm you i'm cleaning
up that car debt before i get married so
you guys can get off on the right foot
and have all of the income stay with you
and is she taking on any debt in into
the marriage no
no yeah i got to tell you dylan george
is right i think you get the roommate
man because that allows you to pay off
the debt
keep your expenses really really low and
tackle that debt i really like that yeah
even even with this raise coming i still
love the idea of you getting a roommate
cleaning up this debt until you guys get
married she moves in that's what that's
what i would do if i was in your shoes
dylan
alrighty well thank you very much there
you go absolutely man now i got you know
the other side of this there's a
relational component to this financial
decision okay
uh i'm not going to throw my buddy's
name out there and throw him under the
bus because you never know who's
listening to the secretary
what if she's listening he might be
um but you got to put some boundaries
out there george because if this is the
place
where your wife to be is going to join
you know what i mean she's probably
going to come over
you got to tell him like clean up man
you know i've been there nothing
institute the uh if it's over a week old
in the fridge it's gone like you got to
put some boundaries in place because
these dudes man they uh they need
boundaries they need to get pretty gross
i'm the clean roommate i'm the roommate
you want you would be a dream
it's too late for you ken that's too
late yeah you would have been great at
that point because you you wouldn't even
know george was in the house he's so
clean and tidy
and uh boy he's got all kinds of phobias
though so there's that yeah that's true
you come with a lot of phobias but you
are a clear point yeah that is good
stuff all right hey don't go anywhere
because we're not your call's coming up
next this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and serving christian
health cost sharing ministry chm has
shared medical expenses for its members
since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm ken coleman i'm
joined by my ramsay personality
colleague george campbell and we're
taking your calls this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
of course we'll take your money calls
george is loaded and ready to go for
that and then i'm gonna help you with
the work side of this component life is
too short to just be living for the
weekend amen and i'm helping men and
women every day on the ken coleman show
part of the ramsey network
discover and do what they were created
to do
because money and meaning are possible
income and impact are there for you
and your mondays should not be miserable
you have a unique contribution that the
world needs and we want to help you make
that so we'll take your work calls
you're struggling with toxic leader
toxic culture not sure what you want to
do you want to level up make some more
money we'll take those calls
as well the phone number to jump in
triple eight eight two five five two two
five now
george we you know we hang out with dave
ramsey long enough you and i've worked
with dave now almost a decade i've known
him for almost two decades the guy's an
icon yeah he's a hall of famer uh and
he's in nashville which means he knows a
bunch of other icons and big shots and
so you get to meet some really cool
people when you hang out with dave and
i've tried to make a living just hanging
out with dave proximity principal come
on here yes my my previous number one
best-selling book thank you george for
the plug but one of the guys that i've
gotten to meet and and and hang a little
bit with uh from time to time uh is
country music superstar john rich of
course if you're a country music fan
no introduction uh if you're not a
country music fan he's one half of uh
the big time country music duo big and
rich um and the guy is honestly as big
of a deal as he is in country music i
think he's a bigger deal as an
entrepreneur i mean the guy's brilliant
incredible big time business mind and
he's also a patriot and he's got a new
show uh not a new show but it is a show
that he launched on fox nation you fox
nation fans out there are familiar with
the pursuit with john rich and now it's
coming prime time on fox business news
and uh you can see it wednesdays at 9 pm
on our very own
dave ramsey is featured on tonight's
show so we thought let's get john on the
line and talk some more about this he
joins us now john rich welcome to the
ramsay show
hey fellas thanks for having me on i'm
excited about uh the world getting to
see me and dave have a really cool
conversation tonight yeah i remember
when you guys were filming that i ran
into you in the hallways and uh what i
love about this show is it's just good
conversation uh describe the type of
conversation you're having with dave and
other guests on the show
well the the basis of the show
is something that i was saying on big
and rich concert stages all over america
and i was getting these huge responses
when i would say it
and i thought you know what they're
responding like that because it's true
and so i decided you know what i'm gonna
make a whole a whole show based on this
concept and it's very simple
america does not guarantee us happiness
it guarantees us the right to pursue
happiness
and in that one sentence guys you can
sum up a lot of the back and forth
fighting that's going on right now
some of our folks think they should have
everything they want when they want it
and if they don't get it then they they
have the right to go out and
pitch a fit
and most people are saying no i'm just
glad i have i have the right to pursue
my dream to go after the american dream
to exhaust my potential the right to
fail and try again and fail and try
again and maybe someday i'll i'll
succeed at it it's it's given to us in
the declaration of independence as an
inalienable right meaning this is not a
right given to us by man given to us by
government this is a right given to us
by god himself
he created us to be
limitless uh in his creation and
anything that limits that is running
adverse to to the absolute foundations
of this country so the show i sit people
down like dave ramsey i sit down eddie
george i had charlie daniels on the show
it's all kinds of people all different
kinds of backgrounds but the one thing
they have in common
is they have
pursued happiness in america and they
have gone through a lot to get to where
they are today and and what i hope the
viewers get out of this is yeah i hope
they're entertained but i also hope that
they get fired up and they get inspired
and that they go wow
i'm taking something on in my life right
now that's difficult everybody's got a
bigger dream than what it is they're
currently doing
and they they learn from these examples
as to how to deal with failure how to
deal with disappointment how to keep
your chin up and remember only america
we're the only country in the history of
the planet
that gives its people the right to
pursue happiness it's our responsibility
to take full advantage of it
he is country music superstar john rich
he's also the host of the show the
pursuit with john rich which airs
wednesdays at 9 00 pm eastern on the new
fox business news prime lineup
uh john i i talk to people about this
every day on the ken coleman show as you
know about discovering that purpose and
discovering work that just fires you up
you think about it you get fired up
you're in the middle of it you lose
track of time you're certainly one of
those people who's living the dream but
you talked about failures a minute ago
and the stories that you share in this
show of very successful people who've
pressed through failure i would love for
you to share with the audience what's it
like from your perspective to be on the
top of the mountain even though it was a
hard climb and you had your setbacks and
failures and fears and all the things is
it worth it
well i still have setbacks that's right
i still have failures and as long as i
continue to strive i will experience
more failures and more setbacks i mean
that that's the nature of this game you
know that
and the only the only time you're not
going to experience more setbacks and
failures is if you're done as if you
stop
and that's just not really in my nature
to be that guy so
you know when i talk to dave this
episode airs tonight you know nine
eastern eight central you guys tune in
and watch it fox business network i'm
talking to dave and what's cool about
this conversation with dave is i've been
friends with dave for a long time
the radio audience everybody listening
right now you know dave pretty well
because dave's pretty much dave when
he's talking but i think i know him even
maybe a little bit better from being his
personal friend and getting to know him
on that level so when i asked dave
about failure
and and buddy his eyes light up he's
excited to answer the question about
failure he's more excited to speak about
the failures
than he was to speak about the successes
because you can't have the successes
unless you have gone through the trial
and error phase and you continue to go
through it and you know dave says
interesting things like if you want to
become really good friends with me
then we need to get in a gigantic
argument about something
why why would a gigantic argument make
somebody a better friend to you dave he
goes because i respect their opinion
that they're willing that they're
willing to you know joust with me a
little bit and then when it's all over
we're friends we give each other a big
hug and we just disagree on that subject
and isn't that what america is supposed
to be all about that we can disagree we
can strongly disagree on many different
things but at the end of the day what do
we still have in common in this country
is there anything we still have in
common in america
i say yes there is it's called life
liberty and the pursuit of
happiness beautifully said john you know
dave doesn't do uh a lot of interviews
these days especially long form in my
eight years here i can count on my hand
and so the fact that he was willing to
sit down with you and do a long-form
interview that shows me that he's got a
deep respect for you and i i saw a promo
for this and i was too i'm like i'm
tuning into this because it's rare to
get to see
two great legendary people sit down and
have a real conversation this doesn't
feel like a like a breeze over media hit
this is real life stuff and you guys dig
deep into his story what he's learned
success the failure is there a thread
that you found between all these people
that you've been interviewing
that is a great question and yes there
is so it doesn't matter
if it's winona judd
or it's uh you know uh eddie george uh
you know it could be a professional
wrestler it could be a big business guy
uh
vivek ramaswamy look up this guy i mean
this guy's just brilliant
indian lives here in america now what
they have in common is is that they
recognize
the blessing that they have to live in
america and have the right to pursue
happiness they know what that means
most of these people that i interview
have had the chance to travel they've
seen other countries they've seen how it
works in other places
and they realize that
if it weren't for america guys can you
imagine what the world would look like
today if america
would have never shown up if america
would have never actually happened how
much different the world would be today
for goodness sake we invented the light
bulb
now we invented rock and roll and
country music and the list goes on and
on and on because we unleash the
potential of our people so everybody i
interview has a deep respect for that no
matter what their politics are they
understand that they are where they are
today because they have the right to
pursue their dreams in this country john
you're a good man it's a great show
check it out tonight the pursuit with
john rich and dave ramsey 9 p.m eastern
on the fox business network check it out
thank you john for being with us more
ramsay show coming right up
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
welcome back america you have joined the
ramsey show and
george campbell and ken coleman we are
thrilled to be with you triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to jump in on the
conversation phone lines are open and
we look across the lobby george and we
see summer standing on the debt free
stage summer welcome hi guys thanks for
having me you bet where are you from i'm
from houston texas houston texas all
right are you a big astros fan i am i'm
really excited to see them win the world
series yeah yeah well i want to mention
that uh i'm pulling for the break oh all
right
man all right we got to make this about
you we got to make this about you uh so
tell us the story how much debt did you
pay off i paid off a hundred and ten
thousand dollars in how long about two
years okay making how much um i started
off at about 73 000 and between a raise
and some side gigs i ended up at about
83 000. nice very good what do you do i
work with kids with autism doing
behavior therapy oh awesome very
rewarding yes unbelievable you have that
spirit about you a very calming spirit i
feel calm right now
i was gonna say you should meet with
georgia the commercial break he's full
of anxiety
oh well that's really fun okay so what
kind of debt was uh the hundred and ten
000. yeah so about 21 000 of it was a
car payment um i paid that off in about
seven months and then um about 89 000
was undergrad and grad school loans of
course yeah wow so i've got a question
yeah you've got you're making 73 up to
83 but you must have been paying 55 000
a year to pay this thing off in two
years how did you do that um so the
first thing was that i moved in with my
parents um they have been amazing so not
having rent really helped and then i
also had a lot of side gigs
i was a dog sitter babysat
did ubereats like whatever i could do
legally to earn money
i'm going to shave every expense i can
yes and i'm gonna increase my income
yeah i just kind of lived off of really
basics just learned what i needed and
what i didn't need and just kind of yeah
put everything i had towards paying off
loans wow and it sounds like you did
nothing but work eat and sleep yeah um i
was not messing around um i just really
wanted to get it out of the way and i
just buckled down i did it okay so give
us the story what happened what was the
impetus two years ago for you to just go
this intense yeah so the year before i
started paying off loans um i did a
mission trip where we went to 11
countries in 11 months
and my plan was to figure out which
country i was going to live in come back
to the u.s fundraise and go straight to
that country to live long term
and i started filling out an application
for a mission organization
and one of the questions was do you have
student loans so i put yes and then the
next question asks what are you gonna do
about those student loans i thought i
don't i have no clue
so i prayed about it and just really
felt like the lord said you need to pay
those off before you can go and do any
mission work
so about two days later i was talking to
my dad he said hey my you know your mom
and i have been talking about it you can
come and live with us as long as you
need to get back on your feet and i said
great how about two years while i pay
off on my debt and they agreed
and a few years ago i did financial
peace university through my church so i
just fished out my little workbook
just started applying the baby steps and
i just did it um that's really all you
know all that's to it wow yeah that's a
fantastic story yeah how much
of your future vision
plays into that story i feel like we got
a little glimpse of it because you you
went around the world and i think george
i've had the privilege to to travel the
world and not a ton but enough that when
you see the world
it changes your entire perspective uh is
there a bigger vision on the other side
of this that also helped drive this
intensity yeah i mean like i said i
really wanted to be a long-term
missionary that's still the goal i don't
really know if or when that'll still
happen
but really right now i'm so open to
whatever god has for me
and now knowing that i can do it
debt-free i feel like the world is my
oyster i really i can do anything and
not have an excuse oh i have to pay my
student loans or i have to do this and i
just feel very free this is huge ken
she's free there's a lot of people out
there who who want to do mission work or
want to do work where they go all right
i don't know what the financial side of
this looks like for support and doing
all these things and you said you know
what it's going to give me more options
and more opportunity if i can clean up
this financial mess and live a debt-free
lifestyle yep that's huge
yeah it's amazing so
uh who were your biggest supporters
obviously mom and dad did a lot for you
who else maybe was a cheerleader for you
yeah my friends were amazing um i still
did you know little vacations here and
there little dinner things but you know
i would
be very upfront and say okay this is my
budget what can we do are you guys okay
with maybe not doing a huge trip but
doing a small trip and um i i just had
so many supporters so many people
cheering me on and i think a lot of
people couldn't understand but they were
still really supportive
that's awesome so what would you say out
of all the things you did what was the
key to getting out of debt yeah i think
um just owning it um i realized that it
was my debt i took out the loans and
nobody was going to pay them off for me
i can't tell you how many people told me
oh you shouldn't be paying off your debt
you know the government's going to
forgive it in a few years and i didn't
know if that was going to happen or not
and i didn't want to take that chance so
i just thought okay this is my problem
i'm going to put it in god's hands and
i'm going to work as hard as i can um
you know to solve the problem so you
said personal ownership is the key
imagine that taking responsibility
taking back control and not putting in
the hands of an outside force and hoping
absolutely that's incredible yeah you're
a rock star thank you absolute rock star
well uh you know when i see a young lady
like this who's got so much future ahead
of her she's got options she loves her
work now i think it's very obvious you
love your work now but then you also
have a heart for maybe doing something
around the globe and as all that comes
to you you kind of kind of go all right
i can move on this i want you to
describe you you know you said you
pulled out financial peace okay i want
you to describe the peace you have even
though you don't know what the path
ahead looks like
i mean i just feel like
it's everything um i no longer have to
worry about
you know maybe one day going into
marriage and having kids and kind of
putting my debt on my kids
like i said earlier i feel like i can
really do anything i don't have to worry
about
oh no i can't spend money to go on this
trip or i can't do this
i really i just feel peace i feel like i
have a great future ahead of me and i'm
excited to do the rest of the baby steps
too you definitely do well thank you so
much thank you for coming here and
sharing your story with us and the
audience as appreciation we want to give
you two books we're going to give you
dave's
legacy journey which is the next step
for you now as you build a true legacy
and i think it's going to be beautiful
and i think you've got a great vision
for it and then we also want to give you
a copy of his total money makeover for
you to give to somebody else maybe one
of those friends who who supported you
but hasn't quite jumped on whatever
you'll know who to give it to so we want
to give you those uh as a thank you for
uh sharing your story with us so you
ready to go i'm ready all right let's do
this summer from houston texas she paid
off a hundred and ten thousand dollars
in two years george whew getting with it
making 73 000
then up to 83 000 summer this is your
moment take it away let's hear your debt
free screen all right three two one
thank you jesus i'm dead free
there you go
she got up there another octave i like
that man i feel like she's got some
pipes ken i think oh you can sing oh
yeah i think it's very possible i love
these stories because you know i kept
thinking as i was hearing her story we
just released this borrowed future
documentary and the stories are stuck
with me the heartbreaking ones where
they went we couldn't start a family we
couldn't buy a house we couldn't do the
work we wanted to do we couldn't live
where we wanted to live because we were
held back by the student loan debt and
she had 89 000 in student loans between
undergrad and grad school and she said
you know what i'm not going to put my
hope in the government i'm going to take
personal ownership personal
responsibility and i'm going to work my
tail off
to create my own opportunity to create
my own options yeah that's inspiring it
is inspiring i tell you what else i just
thought of you know we talk a lot about
when we do these stories we talk a lot
about the piece and what she what she
feels now
and we talk about the struggles but you
know what else beyond the financial
piece and all the options
there is a i did it
there is a
perseverance that has been experienced
this is serious what she did there's no
stopping her this isn't just financial
peace this is grit for the journey to
live
and give like no one else wow summer's
awesome
and so are you you can do it we're going
to help you today don't move
just around the corner more ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america thrilled to have
you with us here on the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman joined by george campbell
we're taking your questions about life
money work and beyond so so much going
on oh boy do we have a lot going on you
were just on uh mornings with maria very
early this morning very early and you
guys were talking about this great
resignation and you unpacked it uh
brilliantly in the time that you had and
everyone's been hearing this word fly
around this morning it's this big this
uh big ominous name people are using
when they talk about massive job
turnover that's what it is it has a cool
name we got to name everything the great
this makes it cooler yeah and so there's
this massive job turnover situation
going on right now and uh you've been
digging into this after a couple of
crazy years people are going hey wait a
minute i don't really like my job i
don't like my situation and they're up
and leaving they're looking for
something better
and you know ken it doesn't have to be
this way this is what you're doing on
the ken coleman show every single day in
your new book from paycheck to purpose
you lay out the proven plan the clear
path to doing work that you love
so if that's you america if that rung
your bell if you don't want to get out
of bed and face another day at the job
you're emotionally spent you're
physically exhausted you've lost your
enthusiasm your juice as ken calls it
for the work that you do and every spark
of excitement you once had then this
book is for you
if you're ready for a change you need to
read this first and get your game plan
ready and if you pre-order today we
sweeten the deal we're gonna send you
over a hundred dollars worth of free
resources like resume templates job
search tools so that you can find a way
to make an income and an impact as ken
loves to talk about plus if you
pre-order by october 30th that's moments
away you'll get the e-book on the 31st
which is two weeks early so you can get
a head start on your reading so hurry up
get your copy of from paycheck to
purpose today at ramseysolutions.com
super excited for that thank you buddy i
appreciate that and just remember my
kids need shoes that's true if you're
looking for just a little extra
incentive i think they need food too
you've got some big boys
isn't that the truth boy costco loves
the coleman so i'll just tell you that
all right let's get to the phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five san francisco california is
where we go now kristen is there kristin
how can we help
hi ken hi um george how are you guys
doing today we are having a blast what's
going on with you
okay so um
my call kind of has to do with the last
guy who called
but in a different sense so my husband
and i got married and we moved into a
house and the roommate that was living
with him before we got married came with
us to the new house which was fine
because it's helped with the bills so we
don't have to cover everything
but now he's basically moved into his
girlfriend
she's stayed every night for the last
four months
she showers here she washes clothes here
she eats here but we talked to him about
it said she needs to start paying rent
if she's going to stay here that much
because we do pay
quite a bit more than him for the bills
here
and he said she's a guest she doesn't
need to pay bills she has to pay bills
um
elsewhere
and we're not really sure what to do if
we should try terminating our lease
early but i know that costs money or if
we should try removing his name off of
the lease if you even know that's
possible
oh boy sticky situation here
so what is the lease agreement what does
it say and who who owns that
um so the lease agreement is my husband
me and the roommate all three of our
names are on it and it's
for a year so we started in june until
next year next june and then
[Music]
per the
regulations it says that there should no
there should not be any subletting and
nobody else besides the people who are
on the lease agreement should be living
here
um that's pretty clear to me and yeah
there's your there's your there's your
technical out have you told him that hey
this is in the lease agreement
um no we haven't told him that
yet
um who's the enforcer who's the who's
the actual enforcer in that contract
the enforcer would be our landlord who
lives we live
about like an hour east of san francisco
but my landlord lives in l.a
yeah well i'd be on the phone really
here to like check yeah well
i mean your technical out is that clause
and the landlord to be your heavy but
this is still going to be a tough
conversation and at some point we got to
be big boys and big girls
and
he either does it your way or
you get the landlord involved
okay yeah
and i hope you've learned a lesson here
i hate to sound like dad oh yeah but
goodness gracious my husband and i are
both like
wow we
are never going to do this again
so you guys are all renting as part of
this lease so it's not like you're
you're not gaining anything financially
other than you have a roommate to split
with correct
yeah so like the
all total we pay like 3 000 for bills
for just to live in the house and he
pays about nine hundred dollars how did
you so we feel like we're housing a
child now well part of me goes it's not
like you own the house is there another
situation obviously i want him out and
to get a better roommate if he's not
going to agree to these terms i don't
like the idea of the girlfriend moving
into the situation either does that
cramp the space a little bit to have
four people in there
um no it's a big enough house for it but
we just feel like he is disrespecting
the agreement that we agreed upon
and
this girl isn't paying anything and
she's staying here for free which you're
not allowed to stay anywhere for free
she's gonna explain that she's got the
great
the greatest gig right now yeah
rent-free in san francisco
yeah how were you guys good friends with
this clown before this or is this just a
sheer my husband
yeah my husband is close friend so
that's where it gets sticky no it
doesn't
thank you very much chris can i just
tell you you need to tell your husband
what i'm saying your husband needs to
man up
my goodness gracious if one of my
friends was doing this to me it'd be a
one-on-one bro conversation come on man
this is it you i your husband should be
ashamed of himself you shouldn't even
have to be dealing with this he needs to
man up and tell this dude
figure it out you play by the rules or
you're out dude but this guy is taking
advantage of your husband he is he has
taken advantage of his kindness or shall
i say taking advantage of his
lack of confrontation skills or a
stomach for confrontation
am i about right
um he's a police officer so he knows how
to have confrontation i think it's the
kindness part that
well he needs to take off the kindness
hat and he needs to put on the
confrontation hat and pull out the old
night stick too
you know i'd be tapping it on my thigh
hey man listen up here you know look
this this is unfortunately ken's saying
this he's being good cop right now we've
got to see a little bit of that bad cop
if you want to see the situation uh be
resolved i don't like if i'm in your
shoes i'm going this guy's out and if
i've got to use the landlord to fix it
if i've got to get the husband to to
have this conversation since his friend
and like you said if it's a friend it's
a different level of conversation
it's not a stranger you met on
craigslist is going hey dude if she
stays here she pays rent that's the rule
george you know me i'm old school man
you are i'm old school i i mean this
might just be grabbing the guy by the
back of the collar and the back of the
pants
ken come on i'm not saying actual
violence i'm saying it's one of those
come on like he just needs to lower the
boom on this guy and go dude you're a
child you're acting like a child but now
let's focus on the backside of this the
lesson here first of all i don't like
the deal that he was paying 900. yeah
they were paying now sometimes they go
well if you've got the master bedroom
with the en-suite bathroom you pay a
little more that's that's
it so i don't know their situation there
but if i'm in their shoes maybe it could
be better to have a stranger who just
keeps to themselves who's clean and you
get a different roommate who you don't
have to deal with did you have any
language in your wedding vows that said
leave and cleave you ever remember that
part i remember that part leaving cleave
if you can't afford an apartment without
a roommate after if you're a married
couple then
you need to slow down you need to do
something less i don't like the idea of
any new married couple quite frank you
know i just don't like it yeah and i
don't know they're in the san francisco
area so they may now they went they're
paying three grand three people maybe
they could find a spot for two grand
that's smaller and still work for them
if they want to be on their own but
living in that area high cost of living
it gets tough because you're going to
pay three four grand on your own but
hopefully the income is there to support
that too if you're looking to just i'm
just there needs to be boundaries for a
new married couple and married couples
in general and having a i mean it'd be
one thing if it's a room over the garage
but sharing one house i don't know dude
yeah but i mean you're younger you're
making all kinds of excuses well we've
we've read the article the millennials
are buying houses together co-buying
with friends oh boy nightmare waiting to
happen ugh all right hey i want to thank
our producer james childs our associate
producer and call screener jenna sears
and you america thank you so much for
joining us this is
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about life i'm ken
coleman joined by george campbell and we
are here for you this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five open phones we're here to talk
about your money we're here to talk
about your work
how do you combine the two can you make
the money that you desire and
have meaning in your work the answer is
absolutely yes there's never been a
better time to do it so george and i
focus on those two key areas money and
work and we want to help you perform to
your peak in both of those areas so
we're here together tag teaming for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to evansville indiana
samuel starts us off samuel how can we
help
hi jason hi george thank you so much for
taking my call i really really do
appreciate it yeah but my name's ken and
he's george not jason
sorry
um i work for a water delivery company
making 39 000 a year
as a class b driver
and i was recently moved up out of the
warehouse because i wasn't working as a
delivery driver every day i would work
in the warehouse some days and then do
deliveries others
and they recently moved me up to um go
out in the field push sales try and
build up business but it was a temporary
thing
they recently told me
that
they want me to go to school and get a
cdl class a license
which would be
include a raise of about eleven thousand
dollars bumping me up to fifty thousand
or if i didn't take that position
they would give me a pay cut cutting me
down to about twenty five thousand whoa
and i've been working with this company
for three years i absolutely love my
boss i love my coworkers i love the work
i do i honestly believe that this god
this job is god's blessing on me for
putting me in the exact right place at
the exact right time
i'm hesitant about being a class a
semi-truck driver for various reasons
including the legal issues that are in
the class a industry and just a lot of
the politics that are in a class a
i've been told that i'll get to keep my
regular delivery jobs i'm being this
semi-truck driver as a substitute for
their other drivers
when they have six days or vacation days
or if an emergency happens and
they need to have a truck rescued
so i'm trying to figure out because
taking the pay cut isn't an option
i'm trying to figure out should i
take this class a position
and move up the chain that way or should
i try to find another job that's a class
e driver job
and try and move up the ladder that way
sounds like to me that that's the option
that's best for you based on what you've
told us you've got some real concerns
and you gave us a quick summary of those
concerns
uh about being a class a driver and i
think you have to stick to your guns on
that um but you can certainly say all
right let's look at those concerns a
little deeper and we don't have to
unpack all those on the phone right now
but as you look at those concerns you go
okay are those legitimate concerns
or are those just some fears and doubts
that i have
because it's new and and it's a bit
unknown and as you dig deeper into those
concerns it's like looking at any fear
or doubt is this fear telling me the
truth and thus protecting me or is this
fear or doubt uh lying to me and holding
me back
i think that's all you've got to do and
i think you've probably done some of
that leg work and so if you have
we already know option b is not an
option you're not going to take a 25 000
pay cut and so option c staying in that
class b lane that you're in doing that
kind of work you really enjoy
in today's environment i don't think
you'd have any problem replacing this
job and you probably get a bump because
i can tell you just on the macro scale
um cnn reported last week
that um there are as many as 70 to 80
000 truck drivers that are needed right
now
across the country wow
so there's a massive need and so even
the class b i'm sure in your area you
can replace this job pretty quickly so i
think you got to trust your gut
have you done your homework on those
concerns and those are valid concerns
i am still doing research i have already
confirmed that a few of them are
fears like the fear of getting pulled
over and being
falsely criminalized because one tiny
little thing on my truck it might be
wrong
but
it is a thing that
most of them are turning out to be more
fears rather than like yeah is this
something that could be a completely
detrimental to me and my career and my
life well i think you you're starting
the process i think you truly look at
this and you have to decide which is the
best path for me you're going to move up
if you take the class a job you're going
to move up if you take another class b
job and do a really good job so i don't
i don't think that there's necessarily a
wrong decision that's sticking out other
than option b we're not doing that we're
not taking a pay cut so i think you sit
with it you pray through it
and you take what is best for you and
george i hear this a lot you know on the
ken coleman show we hear it here on the
ramsay show when we get these calls
you gotta weigh
options based on
what allows me to move further down the
road
and if it's faster great but it doesn't
always have to be faster what's the
right decision for the long term always
the long view here and
obviously in this case the one taking a
pay
uh hit
is not a good move and he's got a way
okay which is the option that i enjoy
the most you know because we don't want
to just take the fastest route if it's
got all kinds of detrimental effects and
harmful circumstances that come with
that it's not worth it and a lot of that
comes from george you and i have
experienced this in our own journeys
where we think well this is the only one
this is the only way i can move up and
that's just not the case no and uh it
seems like a cruel punishment to say hey
if you stay doing what you're doing that
you enjoy you're gonna lose fourteen
thousand dollars a year that's strange
to me i thought i don't like the
ultimatum that he's put in here i know
he enjoys the work the people that he
works with but i would be searching and
i would be going hey who's got the
biggest sign-on bonus to that i could
leapfrog right now and go oh there's
other class b driver jobs out there that
pay 10 20 dollars more and i can do what
i love and george great point because
i'm gonna tell you right now
if you are a driver i don't class a
class b class z
i don't care
huge need right now yeah massive need
uh deliveries are it's suffering the
whole trucking industry is so strong
i mean if you look at supply chain we're
seeing this in the news every day you're
gonna keep seeing it i'm seeing crazy
articles now and headlines that are
saying
christmas uh it's gonna be tough this
year you might not be able to get the
christmas present well we saw that last
year
i mean
yeah we're doing an episode on the fine
print we're putting the finishing
touches on right now around this whole
topic of holiday spending supply chain
what it's going to mean for you as a
consumer but on the job side there's
such a massive need if you're a person
of character with any level of work
ethic and you just show up in your warm
body they go oh my gosh you're amazing
you're looking at pay increases i mean
now is the time to move so uh i gotta
tell you i'm just gonna push this out
there if you or you got a family life
that can support it
and you like being on the open road i'd
be looking into driving a truck right
now they are paying crazy money because
there is a massive need so really
interesting stuff uh thank you so much
samuel for the call you got this all
right
don't move more of your calls coming up
next this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 dollars about two years
after that i got a remote job that pays
me a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
all thanks to what i learned at bethel
tech you could be next get started today
at
betheltech.net and get 1000 to twenty
five hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsey show thrilled to have you
with us i'm ken coleman joined by george
campbell as we take your questions you
need to find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverage you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best deal today's
question comes from grace in wisconsin
i'm 18 years old and currently enrolled
at my first year of community college i
have money saved for my bachelor's
degree in finance so i will have no
student loans
i work 23 hours a week making 15 an hour
at a bank i see job postings all the
time that i'm qualified for have
starting salaries of 45 000 or more
taking into consideration how desperate
employers are in today's job market i
have the potential to make a lot of
money if i wasn't in college should i
continue to get my degree in finance or
go straight into the workforce where i
have a potential to make a lot more oh i
love this question george
you ready i'm ready
yes and yes
continue to get the degree in finance
but i'm going to back off to part-time
online i'm going to slow down the rate
at which i'm getting the degree in
finance because i've already invested in
it and in this case
the finance degree is going to give her
some very viable options
and then i would take the full-time job
at these banks making the 45k or maybe
more so this is a both hand yeah and so
i'm not telling you to stop college i
would slow it down finish online because
you can do that and go start banking the
money george because now she's going to
get
experience
and money
and connections
those are invaluable and the degree she
can just puts along with that and get
finish it off yeah that's huge i mean if
i'm an employer and i'm going all right
do i want to hire someone with no
experience who has the finance degree or
hire someone with four years of
experience
who doesn't have the finance degree
that's you got to weigh those i think
you make a good case and i think at that
point when she says hey i'm actually
finishing my my program but i wanted to
get in the workforce and really start
doing this stuff and gain that
experience if i'm the employer i'm very
impressed already yeah and she's got no
debt yeah which gives her so many more
options
she's not desperate i listen this is the
way that the world has changed you can
finish out a degree online
so i wouldn't even stress
you know she go well look at the
full-time job how many hours should i
take the least amount possible
because you can just keep whittling that
thing down and you're making real money
and making great progress she's at a
community college in her first year so
it's probably knocking out the
prerequisites right now yeah that's like
that free so maybe there are better
options out there to get that finance
and you know what i should i should
thank you for pointing that out because
i should point out i would well i take
the bank job i'd get in there and i
start talking to people that are up the
ladder where she wants to be and say hey
how important is the finance degree
they're probably going to say you need
it
so i so i don't think my advice changes
but i would just add that little caveat
in there depending on which way she
wants to go in finance it may or may not
be required so really good stuff thank
you for your question grace all right
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
toledo ohio home of the toledo mudhens
george i did not know that yeah let's
say yeah
how many unnecessary facts do you have
on your brain i have a lot of them and i
might just start to throw them out there
just to irritate james the producer make
sure he's paying attention over there
behind the board all right let's go to
adam adam how can we help
hey guys i appreciate you taking my call
and what you're doing to help
sure i work in full-time ministry my
wife is a stay-at-home mom who works a
few hours on the sides part time
we have a household income of about 32
000 a year
and working through the baby steps for a
while now we've got our debts all paid
off none of that we got our emergency
funds
funded uh we're contributing fully to
our iras and we got a little bit going
to our
our sons
college fund and as i understand then
the next big thing for us is a home
and
it's been it's been a slow in that
regard we're pretty much throwing
everything in savings we have toward our
our house fund and
kind of
wrestling with this kind of gazelle
intensity toward that that's going to
take several years given the income
we've got now and it seems a little
restricting for us
kind of hinders some extra giving we
could do with that some enjoyment too
but my question is
how how do you think we should go about
funding
our our house do we keep saving throw in
the debt savings account put it in the
mutual funds
we've also
mentioned the idea of just putting off
owning a home
to retirement because right now our we
live in a parsonage the church provides
the housing and that could change but if
we just kind of concede that and say
we'll wait till retirement put our extra
savings toward retirement and just rent
in the meantime should our situation
change i just wondered what you guys
think about how we should go about
funding
our house
yeah we we took a very similar question
on the show yesterday with dr john
deloney and i when they were living in
the parsonage rent-free they also had a
is there a housing allowance that you
could also get
well yeah for some housing expenses i
can i can claim some of that
okay yeah it sounds like i'm living in
the parsonage are they covering all
expenses utilities everything
no they just they own the home we're
just we're living here we pay all the
bills and stuff
you pay all the bills
yes so where where's the upside of this
you said housing is provided
right well they own the home we don't
have to pay rent there's no rental
mortgage payment no rent but you're
paying utilities and right okay that's
pretty that's pretty traditional
like a rental situation got it okay so
they're covering the rent basically so
if i'm you guys i know you have this
income is there is there a trajectory to
make more in ministry going forward
um not
real soon
necessarily and i know your wife is
working a few hours how much bandwidth
do you have to bring in more income i
just it doesn't sound like there's going
to be much more margin in the future to
start saving for a house
right so unless
until if she gets at a point where she's
comfortable working more full-time when
kids get older
or
or my income situation changes
um significantly yeah we're kind of
there's not a whole lot
that we're looking at are you uh are you
a senior are you
adam are you a senior pastor and is it a
uh
what size church is it
it's it's a small church a small town
small church and i'm the preaching
minister there okay yeah so the reason i
asked that adam is because i i'm a son
of a church planter so my dad planted
two churches just recently retired 47
years in the ministry and he always
pastored small churches
and just having watched my dad when we
had to buy houses and do things like
that i mean he took on a second job and
i just wonder how open you are to that
because i think where george is trying
to help you with it's like where's the
extra income and for my dad which was a
pretty similar situation to yours
he went out and he worked extra jobs uh
he took on construction jobs on the side
because you know he didn't have the
traditional office hours of a pastor
with a larger church so are you open to
that type of uh work to be able to bring
in more income
yeah so i do a little bit of that
already my substitute teach sometimes
um
but yeah the time's a little
constricting i don't know if i could do
a good job with my ministry here if i do
have a whole lot more time to work in
okay well i certainly understand that
too and that's that's all very
subjective let me i want to make sure we
answer your question of what a saving
look like where should you park any
extra margin you have and if it's going
to be like a three to five plus year
time horizon you could park that money
in mutual funds of course you can
connect with one of our smart investor
pros in the toledo area and they can sit
down with you and educate you on where
uh the best use of your money might be
and make some recommendations there so
that that money can grow for you at you
know 10 11
for the next five plus years and maybe
that time horizon looks different for
you guys maybe it's ten years from now
if you're going to be in ministry and
have this rent covered there's nothing
wrong with going all right one day we
will own our place but we're gonna have
some patience here yeah and and that's
the key because he's in a very limiting
yeah um financial situation he's just a
small church like that that's the raises
they aren't guaranteed when they come
around they're not very big it's just
it's a smaller church that's just the
reality i certainly know the world that
he's in so yeah his wife working him
being able to uh work some weekend you
know maybe some saturdays but he's
getting ready for sunday so if his day
off is monday does he use that day i
mean he's gonna have to get creative and
you know sell some stuff do some stuff
that yeah it does look different but it
can be done this is gonna take longer
yeah yeah good stuff thank you for your
service uh we appreciate the call adam
all right
hard to believe george got another
commercial coming up
time to rise when you're having fun yeah
we'll be right back this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined
by george campbell and we are here for
you this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five it's a toll-free
call triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to hermiston
oregon where casey and jennifer are on
the line and casey and jennifer it says
here that you guys are here to do a
debt-free screen
yes we are oh that is so awesome how are
you guys
we are good we're
excited to get this uh that out of the
way
i thought they said they were excited to
get the call out of the way i was like
well you made it this far well you know
this is the i like that
that's right that's right but you know
what casey's really saying there i mean
he's pumped and he's like he's like oh
this is the finish line this is the
moment we've all been waiting they've
done the work now now they crossed the
line emotionally so awesome well let's
get to the details uh uh tell us how
much you paid off
we paid off fifty thousand dollars in
the last nine months oh come on now all
right and uh what what was the range of
income during that time uh 110 000 and
now we're up to 160 000. whoa
well you know i'm the work guy the big
shovel guy making more money making more
impact guy i got to know what'd you do
to jump up 50 000.
my wife finished her grad school which
was part of some of our debt and uh with
covet kind of winding down a little bit
here in oregon we were able to do some
more coaching we were both in education
and then a big help is we actually
flipped a house with some friends so
that was huge very nice and by the way
congratulations jennifer on the grad
school
thank you wow that's exciting stuff a
couple years yeah
i can hear the relief uh okay and uh
well we know what some of the debt is
we've already heard some of that but
give us the picture what was the 50 000
in debt was it all student loans
no we had student loans a car loan and
then quite a bit of money for our next
child with ivf but that's all paid off
now oh awesome okay very good very good
i certainly understand that journey uh
all right so
um what do you guys so what do you do
for a living you're both teaching and
education
um i'm i'm a teacher in education i also
coach some sports and my wife go ahead
um i'm a speech language pathologist for
our school district oh very nice casey
what sports do you coach
i coach basketball and tennis oh i love
it don't get ken started on basketball
yeah yeah we'll keep the talk away from
the 2-3 zone versus the man-to-man all
right we won't talk about it oh yeah i
could talk all day about him
i'll bet you could uh we'll spare the
audience and jennifer shall we and me
yeah and george
yeah george has no idea what any of that
means um okay and so what happened
nine months ago
for you guys to go we were on our
computers both uh i was teaching from a
computer and my wife was trying to do
speech language pathology from a
computer um about nine months ago you
know with the whole kobe thing and we
weren't able to coach we weren't able to
do much and so we were home a lot and we
decided we looked at our finances and
we're both into finances but with time
we just didn't want any more bills we
want all our money going to giving and
investing and we are come from some
financial advisors my mom's a financial
advisor and so is my brother-in-law
jen's jennifer's uh
brother so we just yeah we had some
goals we wanted to get to we just need
to get it out of the way
that's incredible so how did you get
connected to the ramsey plan
specifically was it from the from your
mom and the brother-in-law or what
no i just kind of started uh had a
little bit more time on the computer so
i started listening to more podcasts
with the youtube channel and then just
have it on my phone now and then my wife
we've always heard of dave ramsey we
just didn't uh have the time to listen
all the time and now i listen almost
every day at least for a little bit stay
motivated so what exactly did you do i
mean 50k in nine months
making what you guys are making there
were some sacrifices made here
yeah we broke down our car payment to
start and just decided just to put all
our extra money towards our car payment
and then the student loans because we
knew we had the ivf stuff coming up and
so we were home home a lot and just
really broke down our budget and did the
did the envelopes for all our bills
instead of just using our debit card all
the time which really helped you just
went hardcore you were getting real
nerdy going all right what is every
penny doing in our budget because we
want this debt out of our lives yeah we
got a little bit nerdy
that's incredible i love that is when is
baby on the way
we have one daughter albia who's two and
then we're hoping to
have our next one we're going into the
doctor on november 16th with our next
process with ibm okay all right that's
what i was wondering well that's awesome
that is fantastic so who are your
biggest cheerleaders along the way
oh um so my family is
i have a uncle and aunt who
both are coordinating financial peace
university
in sacramento california and my brother
as a financial advisor
did financial peace university a couple
years ago
so they were definitely our biggest
cheerleaders and we would call my
brother like every other
weekend and be like hey what do you
think about this we're always just
running ideas by them that's awesome i
love i want to give the uncle a shout
out what are their names
um ernest and gayle brown
there it is ernest and gail brown solid
coordinator names
say yeah you think so yeah i love that
thank you for coordinating you guys are
on the front lines you didn't just help
out casey and jennifer you're helping
out so many people that is awesome so we
always ask folks that are doing their
debt free scream george and we want to
ask you casey and jennifer what would
you say to people that are listening to
today is the key
to getting out of debt
i would say the key is just talking
about it with with your spouse have to
be on the same page and encourage each
other you know when i talk about biggest
support not only our family but just my
wife we we you know you got to work well
together and once you start seeing that
as dead numbers go down it just feels
good you just feel a nice relief where
you can use your money towards more
important things
communication
monthly communication about finances if
not more
that's incredible yeah that level of
teamwork it's been a threat and a lot of
the debt-free screams i had with any
couple they always go we got on the same
page we started communicating maybe for
the first time in their marriage and it
changes everything way to go guys we're
so proud of you wow so what would you do
yeah what would you guys say to couples
that are listening and they're going i
don't know can we really pull this off
how would you encourage them
i would just say it doesn't really
matter you know your your profession you
just have to sit down and really look at
every single dollar where it's going
especially if you have some debt and how
you can use extra money to go towards
that day because eventually that's going
to go away if you stay focused and not
finished
yeah i love that
well uh that is really great stuff and
we appreciate you guys so much for
coming on and sharing your story we want
to gift you we're going to send you two
books the first book will be the legacy
journey from dave ramsey because that's
the next step for you all as you build a
legacy
you guys are on your way yeah and
we also want to give you a copy of the
total money makeover and we want you to
give that away we want you to decide who
needs that book and we trust you we know
it's gonna do good things so that is a
gift for you to give away uh as our
appreciation for you all sharing your
story so you guys ready to go
we are now are you in separate rooms i'm
guessing
no i joined the lunch work time we
zoomed over real quick all super excited
okay here we go they're ready to go
george it's casey and jennifer in
hermiston oregon they paid off 50 000
in nine months making first 110 000 all
the way up to a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars casey jennifer this is
your moment let's hear your debt free
scream
three two one
[Music]
jennifer going
she's going after it they went ham yeah
coach started laughing did you hear him
he started he started giggling man and
jennifer just took it baby that was that
was awesome that was that's the half
court shot yeah especially
the goal on the phone is to do it so
loudly you distort the phone quality and
it gets garbage you're a musician i
think she did this number does she throw
the head back and kind of take it up i
felt that i think you're right ken you
know good observation yeah you know you
see these musicians at concerts they hit
the big note and they kind of pull away
from the mic and you and james know more
about that than i do but i feel like she
really took it to the roof yeah very
impressive yeah great story yeah you
know i got to give coach a hard time
jennifer outplayed him on that one i you
know i love casey i love coach but uh
you love a good sports reference too
well i do and during the break george
i'm gonna teach you the difference
between a 2-3 zone
and man-to-man defense my brain just
melted a little bit i know it might take
a while it's gonna be great it's gonna
be a great conversation starter for you
in the future you'll thank me for it hey
folks don't go anywhere this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show it's where
people congregate to have a conversation
about serious stuff like life money your
work
your relationships
we're here to help you i'm ken coleman
joined by george campbell
and we are here for you the phone number
to jump in on the conversation
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five
so how many of you out there are among
what is being reported as millions of
americans looking to change jobs in the
next year
4.3 million people left their jobs in
august george it was a record
economists are calling it a great
resignation
and that's why we're hosting from
paycheck to purpose live on thursday
november 11th at 6 45 pm central time
it's based on my new book under the same
title from paycheck to purpose it's
going to give you the plan you need to
get unstuck find your dream job and
leave a legacy here's the truth you
don't have to choose between making an
income
and making an impact
you can make money
and experience meaning it's time to go
from just collecting a paycheck to doing
the work you were created to do join us
via live stream or we have limited spots
it's going to be fun experience live
here at our ramsey solutions headquarter
as i walk you through the clear path to
finding the work that you love event
passes start at just ten dollars that's
crazy george we should be charging
triple that feels like i gotta talk to
the team about that ten dollars ah i
don't know event passes start at ten
dollars learn more by texting the word
purpose
to three three seven eight nine text the
word
purpose to three three seven eight nine
it's gonna be a fun event it's gonna
equip you it's going to encourage you
and it will entertain you i can't
believe we're selling it for ten dollars
george i keep looking at that it's not a
typo and uh this is a great event i was
at the get clear live stream event that
you did a little while back and it was
powerful yeah especially if you can be
in the crowd yeah there's some special
moments and we're doing something unique
i i told the team we we got together we
started brainstorming we said let's do a
really intimate setting to create an
even better video visual setting for the
crowd that's going to watch it via live
stream so um we'd love for you to join
us either on the live stream or in
person
purpose is the word text that to
33789 let's go to orlando florida ellen
joins us there ellen how can we help
hello thank you for taking my call you
bet what's up
okay um so i have a car question i'll
just give some
um at the end of the divorce
and
i'm on a every dollar budget i don't
have any debt i'm building up my
emergency fund
in addition to that i have a fifteen
thousand dollars in an investment
account and i'm expecting a fifteen
thousand dollar settlement okay um
now i have a car that i got about
a year ago i bought it for thirty five
hundred dollars and
it's been having some problems lately i
was told that i would have to put in
about two thousand dollars to be able to
keep it
running properly
and i can sell it now for three thousand
so i'm looking to sell that car and then
buy something else and the question is
how much to spend on that do i stay
within that type of a limit or do i go
for something
yeah good question what's your household
income
40 000 and then
child support of
1400 a month
okay
and you're working on building this
emergency fund how far away you from
completing that
so right now i have 3 700 in it my goal
is 22
800 to be in fact
and um that fifteen thousand dollar
settlement is going straight into there
perfect so the settlement will come
we'll get you through baby step three
and you said you have 15 000 in
investments what kind of investments are
those
um
so if that's an investment like that my
grandparents set up for me um it's like
it has a 11.4 percent return on
investment from what i saw
okay um i've never touched it i've never
taken anything out of there before and
these are just like are they stocks
mutual funds it's non-retirement right
non-retirement right okay
if i'm you i'm using that settlement to
fully fund the emergency fund and i'm
going to take a portion of those
investments and use that to upgrade your
car and you could cash flow it it just
might be a little longer which means you
might have to use this car for another
six months if you want to save up and
pay cash for it and not touch the
investment but since it is you could
liquidate those investments with no
penalties other than your your capital
gains so i would talk to a tax pro you
can find those at ramseysolutions.com
to figure out what the tax implications
are of taking out a chunk of those
investments you're just going to pay
taxes on the gains but it may be short
long term depending on your situation so
if i'm you you're asking how much cars
should i buy i don't think you need to
get crazy
with your income and with your financial
situation i want you to be able to move
through the baby steps start investing
15
and if you've got kids start saving for
college and pay off your house after
that so to do that i want you to have
margin
and right now getting a getting a car
even with cash i don't want you spending
20 grand on a car
um but you could spend five you could
spend six and get you something uh
that's gonna get you from a to b
right okay so if you sell yours for
three that means you only need to pull
three from the investment account to get
a six grand car right
right i mean the car
people that i've been speaking to have
been advising me that i'm not really
gonna get much better and i'm still
gonna have all the problems that i have
um because of the used car market now
yeah i'd get this thing uh out of your
life and get something a little bit more
reliable and if you can get three grand
for it even with its issues i'd say get
rid of that thing and you've got money i
just don't want you dipping into your
emergency fund because let's be honest
it's not an emergency you know this is
coming you know the car is on its way
out so i don't want you to have a moment
you go well i got this emergency fund
and the car broke down so i'm going to
spend 20 grand on a car let's get
something reasonable for now and here's
the thing you can upgrade that car later
on maybe you make a little more money
you feel like you're in a good spot
financially you put some a sinking fund
going in your every dollar budget and
you go i'm going to put away 500
this year order this month and i'm going
to add that up and once i hit 8 grand
i'm going to upgrade the car again and
you can keep doing that yeah did you say
that uh that putting the 2000 in the car
the current car would actually make it
run well or your mechanics are saying
it's just a band-aid
um
they say it will take away the problems
for now but i haven't found it to be a
very reliable car what kind of car is it
it's a nissan pathfinder 2007.
okay
yeah i think i think okay i think in
this situation but do you think you can
get three with all the problems it's
having
yeah i have someone that's willing to
take it for three oh all right well i'll
take the three
and uh and then i would go get something
in the five range fight you can get some
stuff that's pretty dependable but do
your homework my car was six grand oh
nine honda civic runs like a champ yeah
yeah listen the hondas the toyotas take
your homework i mean these cars are very
very do you have a car in mind that
you're looking to buy
um not specifically okay
that's just my my hot take is if i if
you're looking for reliability honda and
toyota
but yeah you can do your homework uh you
can do your homework and uh i'm gonna
tell you right now i'm i'm looking all
the time because i got a 15 soon to be
16 year old and uh i could tell you
ellen they're they're they're decent
cars that can be very dependable in that
five grand range for sure yeah and
here's the deal
the dave ramsey method
where you just show up with five grand
in cash
and you look it over you mull it around
ask lots of questions
very emotionally detached
not desperate at all not at all very
really excited barely like why am i even
here all right because they want to move
the car anybody selling a car for five
wants to move the car
all right so then you go all right uh
well
i'm thinking uh
well you just pull it out of your pocket
and you just count out
four thousand you go would you take four
and then let them react if they say no
absolutely not five thousand
hard price i'm not moving great then you
got option if you want it you can buy it
but i like going at four george because
i like them in my mind coming back at 46
and you go would you take 42
a little negotiation you say where this
goes see where this goes be smart about
it and you're thinking people say cash
ken you can't get a car for that in this
market oh yeah have you looked have you
checked facebook marketplace i'm telling
you this you can yeah you can
i'm wearing out facebook marketplace i
had no idea this existed i didn't know
you're on facebook and i'm very
impressed well i should point out that
i'm only the the ramsey solutions uh
social media team okay but i have a
dummy account that's the way to do it
and i go in there nobody knows i'm there
and i'm just on the facebook marketplace
that's so good yeah just sold a car by
the way on facebook marketplace way to
go it can be done ken coleman did it
yeah oh boy let me tell you something i
am the low bar if ken can do it anyone
can all right hey i want to thank kelly
daniel and james childs will thank you
george campbell thank you for hanging
out with us
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show
it's where america is hanging out to
have a conversation
purposeful conversation about life about
money about your work about your
relationships
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight
eight two five
five two two five george how you feeling
today feeling wonderful feeling good
yeah i like the sweater today you like
that it makes me think of fall and
pumpkin spice lattes really yeah really
the light blue does that yeah yeah you
now see the green that to me feels a
little bit pumpkin spice latte which by
the way i want to point out not a fan
really i haven't jumped into the craze i
know this about you we've traveled
together you're a peppermint mocha guy
james kelly is pointing at james james
you like the pumpkin spice i like it if
you you know put a few less pumps of
syrup in there so it's not so sweet the
flavor i'm a fan of yes okay so light
pumpkin spice okay kelly and i are on
the no way train good for you let's see
kelly and i we see this is the content
america's here for
well i think i think people are
listening they're going you're either in
one camp for the other i don't think
there's middle ground plus any time we
can get james to give us any personal
information it's a win in my book is
that right yeah he's fort knox man is he
really i don't even know if his real
name is james
no proof you know what i'm gonna tell
you something folks james childs long
time producer of the ramsey show i find
him to be delightful i really do he's
quiet i never said he wasn't delighted
but i don't think that he would if i
asked james like you know tell me your
favorite band i think he opens up like
you know like crazy i think he just he
turns into a you know like one of us
just gab and gab and gamma the guy likes
his music you know yeah yeah she's happy
to talk about that and we're happy to
talk about you so let's get to it andrea
joins us in topeka kansas andrea you're
on the ramsay show how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call so i have a
financial question of course but um i'm
on baby step number three um
i have a kitchen repair
that needs to be done with eve sooner
than later because i have
the new dishwasher staying there but the
cost is to fix is going to be about
hundred twenty three dollars and i'm
just a little nervous about spending
that money even though it needs to be
done eventually
because
it's just a lot of money out the door
when i have other expenses how far away
are you from fully funding the emergency
fund
um so i think i need about um 9 300 for
about three months but for six months i
was thinking about about almost nineteen
thousand um i am a single mom so there's
only one income
so i'm just trying to plan accordingly
what's your take-home pay every month
i take home pay uh 4 395
and then i have about approximately
three hundred dollars of child support
okay
that's great so how far are you into
this emergency fund
i'm about nine thousand oh so you have
three months currently
oh yeah i almost yeah just just like
just now that's great good for you hey
uh just a quick question you said the
the new dishwasher is in the kitchen it
just needs to be installed
well i have the old dishwasher is about
on a glass lake i purchased a new
dishwasher um over labor day
um when they were on sale
so that was sitting because i thought it
was going to die
sooner they're still chucking drugging
on
so it's sitting there packaged in my
in my between my dining room and living
room right there my point is the 3 125
that's the cost to install it
no it's to um replace all the
countertops so like my house is an older
house so the floors were uneven so when
i moved in we fixed the floors and then
now i have to either rip up the floors
which i don't want to do because they're
new and or rip up the countertop which i
don't like anyways so um i see i got you
i got you i'm tracking with what the
cost is okay i got you okay so how long
would it take for you to get to that six
month emergency fund
how many more months uh
probably like another
six to seven i also paid for private
school um
and so like that takes up a chunk of my
budget so not a lot of margin to to
continue on with the baby steps right
now
yeah i i have about
thirteen hundred twelve
i've had a lot of home repairs so that's
kind of slowed down the process but um
comfortable like about
a thousand to thirteen hundred dollars
every month of extra margin yeah good
for you that's great well you're
crushing it as a single mom you're doing
some incredible work if i'm you i mean
i'm finishing out this emergency fund to
get you in a good solid financial
foundation and i'm dealing with the old
countertops i'm dealing with the old
dishwasher and uh if the dishwasher goes
out i mean hand wash them you can hand
wash them for a month could you do that
i guess i hate i hate washing dishes i
know i'm with you get it i get it but
it's just you and and and how many
kiddos
uh just one oh my gosh we're doing paper
plates
can i just tell you that's exactly where
i was going first of all i mean you're a
single mom you're a superhero okay
andrea you're amazing so you can wash
the dishes but if it's that big of a
deal i'm with george i'm going paper
plates and paper cups it's just you and
the kiddo and i'd also get some extra
quotes on the repairs yeah i think that
could be that it feels high to me but
depending on what you got going on i
would at least get a few quotes from
some contractors in the area and go hey
does this you know what would you charge
for this to see if you can speed up that
process because if it's two grand well
that's great that might speed up the
process by a month or two as well yeah
okay you got us
one other question on this because i'm
trying to help you save even more money
and do all this faster i want one more
idea
okay are you involved in in the
community you have a good uh group of
friends around you maybe go to church or
you plugged in somewhere to a friend
group or church in any way
um
not quite yet i moved here a year ago my
parents are relatively really involved
and they're gonna do some of the work
with a friend but um
that yeah i i'm pretty relatively new i
have family and stuff but i'm not i
don't have a community okay here's the
deal even at my church andrea i really
love the fact that your parents are
there and they're involved and they're
gonna help i'm telling you right now you
can beat that thirty one hundred dollar
and twenty five dolla i mean thirty one
let's call it that i can't talk to you
yet george but you can beat that andrea
i'm telling you you can beat that with
help and people pulling in there the
demo on that there's friends that could
come in that have some construction
background or whatever your dad's got to
know somebody that can come in and do
that demo and we could probably do that
for half of that cost okay
yeah and then maybe i need to change
maybe it's the because it's the counter
and the sink um i get it it's going to
cost about that i get it but i'm telling
you my parents told me to do it
well
appreciate that but if parents can make
some connections for you and you and you
just kind of see who'd be willing to
help you to come in and help a single
mom out are you kidding me yeah you know
parents told you to do it but they're
not paying your bills so it changes the
the situation appreciate the advice mom
and dad but i'm over here doing my thing
should really change out the countertops
yeah it'll be three grand well you
should do it yeah yeah let's get some
help let's see if we can we can cut
costs here people want to help single
moms they ought to if i knew somebody in
topeka kansas i'd be on the phone on the
commercial break yeah go let's help her
out yeah but i get her predicament ken
you know where i'm a millennial me and
my wife we don't live on little house in
the prairie i didn't sign up for
dishwashing by hand but you can do it
for a season
to get a good financial foundation
oh these gen xers well you walked up
hill both ways let me guess i did but i
also still wash my own pots and pans we
don't put them in the dishes sure well
then you can wash the rest of them all
right but we even came up with a paper
plate idea which i thought was brilliant
we were both there
that's a classic dude you could buy
eight months worth of cups at costco for
twelve dollars go today all right we we
gotta take a quick break but we're
coming back this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by george campbell and we're
taking your calls
to help you move forward in your life
you want to move forward in your work
do something you love make a bigger
paycheck which will help you get through
the baby steps faster
i'm your guy that's what we do on the
ken coleman show on the ramsey network
and then of course george is going to
help you with your money questions as
well so we're here together triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the last 18 months have been well
i don't even know what you call them
just a lot
wow you wanted to say unprecedented but
you held back is that right
yeah we've put a kibosh on that word
around here no more
if we removed it from the lexicon pivot
unprecedented it's all gone we're done
with it yeah that sounds like something
dave would say uh but either way uh
it is uh make you wondering what in the
world is next right because you don't
know i mean we felt like it was going to
be slowing down i thought it's going to
be getting better now inflation now
we're talking about are we going to even
have christmas presents in the stores
it's just always something new to worry
about it really is in the headlines it
really is uh so anyway maybe that's how
you feel about your money too you're
tired you're stuck you're stretched thin
you don't know how you're gonna get out
of it you don't know what's next what's
the next thing you're gonna have to pay
for but it doesn't have to be that way
all you need is a plan because the plan
gives you confidence that when
everything else seems out of control you
can control the money and that plan is
financial peace university this class
will teach you everything you need to
know to save money pay off debt and
build wealth for the future you can
stream the lessons on your own or get
support by going through the class with
others then you'll put that plan into
practice with the premium version of our
every dollar budgeting app by syncing
your bank to your budget you can easily
track your spending and see where your
money goes you get all of this only with
a ramsey plus membership you don't have
to stay exhausted or overwhelmed you can
win with money start your free trial of
ramsey plus by texting trial to 33789
that's trial text that word to 337
eight nine los angeles california the
city of angels taylor is there taylor
how can we help
hey guys how are you doing today well we
are living the dream taylor what's going
on with you
all right well i'm i'm out on a walk
with my 18 month old daughter and it's
sunny and 75 so i can't complain too
much it it it could be worse it could be
worse it's happy california i'll take it
very nice
like that i like yeah i see what you're
doing there george you don't have to
take that from him taylor
that's all right you know it's okay well
it is what it is yes some california
than some island so i'm a little mixed
blood all right
how can we help
oh um i got a question for you guys um
basically it is what would you do with
our money financially in the current
situation that we're in
um so i'll give you a kind of a
background here as quick as i can
my wife and i got married about five
years ago or so and at that time she
took a position with chapman university
she's a professor in accounting out here
um in actually orange california is the
exact town and i own a business it's a
higher end bicycle shop like pedal bikes
and road bikes back in iowa
we are split
in terms of where we live about seven
months in california five months in iowa
my busy season is in iowa which is
basically her off season because she's
on an academic schedule
so we spend most of our summers in iowa
and we spend the rest of the year out
here in california now we've gone
through pretty much all the baby steps
um we don't have debt uh what we do have
are two homes in a commercial building
now
uh we have a home here in california
it's on a 30-year mortgage at 2.6
percent
we have about 550
000 left on that
it is valued at about 870 000. so um our
home back in iowa we have a home there
on a 15 year at 1.9
we have about
98 left on that
and
that is valued at just over 300 000
and then we have a commercial building
that we purchased last year that my
business rents from so my business is a
c corp
and that then rents from us is landlords
now the reason we purchased that and
have a mortgage on it and didn't pay
cash is because we were very strapped
with a time issue so it would either
close the business up or
purchase the building and rent from it
it's kind of a weird thing i got
diagnosed with a toxic mold poisoning
and that's a whole nother
that's a whole nother thing
um
yeah it's it's a it's a weird thing so
like like i'm like i said it's a kind of
a weird situation i think you know nine
times out of ten we would say go this
way but we might be that one up one out
of ten time that
it just didn't it didn't it didn't make
sense and we weren't ready necessarily
to completely uproot our life in iowa um
and the reason being is we don't know if
we're going to be here in california
because my wife her job
uh we probably have two
maybe three bills left here that she
doesn't get tenure so she's a 10-year
track professor
but if she doesn't get 10-year after
that two or three year mark then we
would most likely move back to iowa
and so
our our biggest thing is like we have
extra kind of cash flow coming in would
you throw that at
homes or would you put that in to like
an investment retirement account why we
have that cash flow because you don't
think that that's going to stay there
forever and that amount of money can
grow pretty quick most of our like we
have 270 000 in the retirement account
um we've got about
75 000 in alternative investment
accounts
those are right now are
anywhere from 12 to 17 they've been
pretty consistent and then we've got you
know a 30 000
um
emergency fund and then it's about 20k
in savings
what's the savings for you guys have any
goals with that
um it's honestly it's just like a
i i don't know if i like an oh [ __ ] fun
like if something happened big time
where like
you know business issue building expense
that type of deal
um we just kind of have it that my wife
just kind of likes to have it there
what's the alternative investment what's
that about
um it's just like there's some real
estate in there um there's
some art there's some supply chain
financing there's some
um so if you wanted to today could you
liquidate that and get 75k in cash
uh within a year yeah within within any
of them still have about six to eight
months left yep well looking at these
numbers i mean i know you're asking
should i do cash flow they do cash flow
yeah well yeah so they have
stuff if you're following the baby steps
i want you to have a paid for house
before we continue building wealth
before we continue investing uh so that
means we're not going to continue this
investing track i know you're seeing the
money grow you're going to hate it's
getting 12 to 18
and it's been a great bull market but
what i want you to do is get rid of that
iowa house it's 98 left on that i mean
you could with your savings and those
alternate investment accounts you could
basically pay that off this year
yeah that would free up the iowa
mortgage payment to then attack the
california payment if you wanted to do
that i know you guys may not be there a
long time but you're going to build that
in your in your equity anyways when you
go to sell it so that's what i would do
that's the ramsey plan before we go into
and you're going to have your the rest
of your life to go wild with investing
but right now you're sitting here with
three mortgages the commercial mortgage
and at some point that could put you in
a real bind financially so i want you to
have options and right now you guys have
a great income and things are great but
at one day things may not be great and
you're going to have these payments to
make so i would clean up the iowa debt
get rid of that mortgage attack the
california one and then work on that
commercial one and liquidate anything
you can that doesn't have any tax
implications retirement accounts things
like that
georgia stellar stellar job i have
nothing to add other than it just it
kind of amused me
as we begin to move from iowa to
california california back to iowa it's
a fascinating situation you don't hear a
lot about people splitting their time
between iowa and california and i just
gotta imagine that is like it's like
going from mars to venus isn't it a very
different situation i would think so
this is a young couple they're going we
have a california home in our iowa home
and they've done very well very well
it's clearly a crushing i would just
simplify i think you're right it's
simple
right now you know baby young baby by
the way i thought he did a nice job of
walking the streets
he kept his he wasn't winded no i was
paying attention to that too shape yeah
very in shape yeah you did such a good
job on answering that money question
george i was there's a lot going on i
was locked in on his heart rate what i
thought it might be you know
i appreciate that glad you're being
observant in some way shape or form well
you did a good job there's nothing else
i could add to that there's a reason why
you're where you're a i'm a nurse i like
the numbers you like the numbers you do
good with the numbers thank you
fantastic
all right folks don't move more of your
phone calls coming up this is the ramsey
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience
if someone from that company likes your
profile they can personally invite you
to apply for the job so if you're ready
for an easier job search check out
ziprecruiter sign up for free right now
at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell we are here for you america
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number it's a
toll-free number phone lines are open
triple eight eight two five five two two
five all right george let's go to
winston-salem north carolina and that's
where tyler joins us tyler how can we
help
hey how are y'all doing well we're
having a blast i've been
yeah well i've been uh
scrambling on youtube at every
episode
a lot of it does help but it doesn't
really match like my predicament me my
fiance are in
so i thought i'd call and just share a
little bit great see what y'all thought
right
um so we just both graduated from school
we have uh both just got jobs recently
in the past two months
our
household income right now that's on
track to be about a hundred twelve
thousand here sorry try one more time
speak directly to the phone
um we're getting married in june okay we
have about a hundred and twelve thousand
dollars of household income okay
um myself is 49 000 of that
we have 23 000 as of now in savings both
of our savings account
we have no debt no car payments we'll
both live at home with our parents so
we're not really paying any bills
besides going out to eat and doing like
leisure things
did we lose you yeah i think his his
face
you're coming in and out are you in one
place you're moving around what's going
on
i don't know i'm in one place i'm in my
office okay let's so i heard 23k in
savings there's no debt you're both
living at home and then it went quiet so
what's your question
hey so
with our current position
we don't know whether like the way the
market is if we should like use that 23
000 we have in savings so maybe look at
land maybe invest in some land and start
making payments on our land and then
maybe potentially building a house on it
or possibly just starting to just keep
saving all the money that we're making
months a month
and then debating on if we should rent
or go straight into like a 15-year
mortgage
that's a great question uh what's the
deal with the wedding are we cash
flowing that who's paying for that
uh we're being we're both blessed our
parents are paying for it so that's
something we're both thankful for and
when is the wedding
in june so we got some time so from now
until then i'm stacking up as much cash
both of you
uh saving up as much as you can so that
when you enter this marriage maybe you
got a big pile of money and what i don't
want i actually don't want you to jump
into a 15-year mortgage or some land i
want you guys to rent for a little while
and get the hang of marriage yeah that
should be your focus where you invest
your time and while you do that you can
still be saving money while you're
renting and i know it feels like for you
because you guys have done so well
you're going wait we're not going to
throw money on away on rent but here's
what it's going to do it's going to set
you guys up not only financially but in
your marriage there's a lot there's a
whole lot of learning curve to marriage
and home ownership added on to that is a
big pile of nightmare so i want you guys
get some footing under yourself maybe
you sign a six to twelve month lease
and then start to dream together and go
what do we want to do yeah and uh
land you know while it's great to buy
some dirt
is that her dream too and does she want
to be in a single-family home and not
wait three years for the hopes of
building a house on this land so if i'm
you guys i'm renting for a little while
with a big pile of cash you're
continually saving up make sure you're
you've got that emergency fund in place
three to six months of expenses you're
both investing 15 percent uh and then at
that point you're gonna have a big down
payment and maybe you can even pay for
in cash i mean how old are you two
well we're both 23 years old
unbelievable you guys are going to be
set up if you do this stuff and you
follow the baby steps you'll be able to
pay cash for a place uh before you're 30
at this rate with right now with that
what's that 23 000 we have in savings
and now i'm
kind of debating if we should just act
like we don't have 10 000 of that so
that's our emergency fund like we don't
even just forget we have it and if we
need it we have it but
just act like we have 13 000 and just
keep adding to that well here's the
thing you don't know what life looks
like when you're married you don't know
what your expenses are yet and so once
you do get married whatever you need for
three to six months of expenses you're
gonna add up here's a month of what our
life looks like let's multiply that by
three or six if you both have great
stable incomes you can lean towards
three and the rest of that money can go
towards your next goal
which it sounds like you guys want to
get into some real estate buy something
and i'm all for that uh and with your
position at 23 years old making you know
six figures in a good financial spot
with no debt you're gonna be able to get
there in no time
and if you do it you mentioned 15 years
so i love that 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage where the mortgage payment is
no more than a quarter of your
collective take-home pay that's going to
give you guys margin to continue the
baby steps to save for the future to pay
off the house early all of those great
things so you you guys are doing great
congratulations on the wedding yeah fun
fun fun let's go to malachi next in
rogers arkansas malachi how can we help
hi uh yeah thanks for taking my call
george and ken i really appreciate it
you bet
um so i i really struggled with how to
phrase this question um but i'm 22 i've
got a beautiful wife and two adorable
children um i'm only making 16 an hour i
don't have a degree thankfully i don't
have any debt
um but our rent's going up it's it's
getting to the point to where
um we can't really do anything
significant i can't put away for
retirement um i can't put anything into
a savings account um and basically the
most we could put into savings each
month each month is about a hundred
dollars
um you know just leaving even just
leaving a little bit of extra money for
you know unexpected stuff or
you know um like if we need to get an
extra thing a diaper or something so i'm
really just not sure what to do um
as far as options go there's not really
anything else in my area that's
comparable
um what are you doing now you know
family
um as far as career goes yeah
um i worked at a t-shirt shop um which
is i mean they're super nice people um
and it's a great gig and it you know i
was unemployed prior to that and so i
don't know unemployed but for a time i
had been
um
and so but i mean there's really not
much room for advancement if i if i stay
there 20 years i'll probably be here
the same thing i'm doing today how big
of an area is rogers arkansas
i mean it's the it's in the northwest
arkansas area so it's pretty big i think
it's one of the fastest growing areas in
the country um but it doesn't um
really have any of the industry that i'm
wanting to go into what industry do you
want to go into publishing
publishing book design formatting and
like typography and stuff okay
well so
if that's the industry you want to be in
where where are those jobs
i'm i'm really not sure okay let me help
you out okay so nashville's got a lot of
publishing jobs okay you need to do your
homework on this you know because you
can't sit there you've got a family to
take care of and 16 an hour is barely
getting you by and it's also 2021
and you said you're in a really good
area northwest arkansas my goodness
walmart's out there bentonville all that
area and and we're in a situation where
uh companies are begging people to show
up
dude you can make way more than sixteen
dollars an hour
and you should be making way more than
sixteen dollars an hour not at the
t-shirt shop it's time to get busy this
is an income issue you've got to
discipline you've got the know-how
you're doing a good job you still don't
have enough income
and and so we have two issues we have
short term and long term the short term
that's what i just addressed i'm kind of
kicking in to see the pants and going
get out there if you got to drive a
delivery truck you can make 20 22 an
hour okay get out there and get busy
you're not wanting to go into t-shirts
anyway so go wherever wherever you can
go right now and get more income now
then once you get stable and you can
breathe a little bit
then you can allow yourself to say okay
uh if i wanted to move to the nashville
area to get into publishing or new york
or wherever wherever you got to do your
homework that type of work you want to
do where are the best places to do it
it's not just an area where the
companies at that are looking for talent
are you qualified if you're not malachi
what is it going to take for you to get
qualified how much is that going to cost
based on your budget how long is that
going to take well these are questions
you need to answer after you start
making more money and get some margin do
you understand what i'm saying
yeah yeah absolutely come on yeah i
appreciate you hitting me in the butt a
little bit listen you got a lot to offer
you hear that more thank you yeah you
know what you need you need a picture of
that family you had a picture of that
future
in your head all the time get out there
man if you got to do two jobs right now
there's plenty of money to be made
you have an income issue that's it get
the income up walk the baby steps out
get called qualified for the future that
you want and step into it you got this
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell our scripture of today
comes from isaiah 58
11 the lord will guide you always he
will satisfy your needs in a
sun-scorched land and will strengthen
your frame you will be like a
well-watered garden like a spring whose
waters never fail today's quote from zig
ziglar you are the only person on earth
who can use your ability love zig love
the simplicity but always a lot of depth
behind zig so amazing man yeah great
dude i never got to meet him
dave talks about him one of dave's
heroes but never got to meet zigg
unfortunately all right let's get back
to the phone lines let's go to luke in
phoenix arizona luke how can we help
i'm good how are you
we are having a blast what's happening
today luke
i just have a quick question um at the
beginning of the year
i am receiving and it should be a yearly
thing as long as i'm in the job i am but
it's a profit share check that i'm
getting for
somewhere between 40 and 50 000 next
year and i'm just wondering like how do
i budget that with the rest of my income
what's your household income
um so my regular salary is 72
and then my wife is in real estate and
somewhere between 80 and 100 she makes
depending on the year so total household
income is somewhere in 150 to 170 range
maybe
yeah okay and then that bonus is going
to move it the bonus will move it up to
closer to two that's fantastic
way to go man that's awesome so where
are you guys at give me a financial
picture of where you're at have you been
following our baby steps
um yeah we're working through them now
we should hopefully we're selling a
rental property we have those out of
state thank god and
that should eliminate almost all of our
all of our debt plus give us our
emergency fund fantastic so that'll put
you at baby step four where you guys are
investing 15 of your household income in
retirement
yeah
okay and do you have a primary residence
yeah we already own a house and it's
paid for
no it's not okay it's on a mortgage
what's the mortgage on that
uh
450
450 and what's the house worth
uh
six
six six and a half
okay so if i'm you guys i mean we i'm
applying this money to your goals and
treating it kind of like in a regular
income thing and so if i'm you if i got
forty thousand dollars today i'm
slapping that thing on the house and
paying that mortgage down i mean you've
got a sizable mortgage there and so if
you keep putting that bonus towards that
on top of any extra margin you have past
baby step four do you guys have kids
yeah we have two okay so once you start
investing that 15
into maybe your 401k roth iras things
like that then you're going gonna start
socking away some money for the kids
college fund i'm guessing they're a
little younger
yeah five and one perfect so we've got a
lot of time put that money into some
esa's 529s things like that to let that
money grow tax-free so that when they go
to college if and when they do you'll
have money to pay for that
and then on top of that you're at baby
step six which is where we're paying off
the house early so once you've got these
plates spinning you've got your
investments for retirement you've got
the investments for kids college any
extra margin and any extra bonus i want
going towards that house
and if you do that i mean it sounds like
in a few years you guys could have a
paid for house that's worth 650 or more
okay should i set any of the money aside
for tax purposes wise i'm kind of
worried because it's going to be w2
income but i don't know like how that's
how that they don't they don't take
taxes out of that bonus
we yeah no it will be taxed but like uh
just it doesn't get taxed at the right
rate because
they just when you the w-2 is just
accounting for my income it doesn't
because my wife is just as uh
um
it's all 10.99 so
none of hers isn't so basically there's
there's extra taxes that are are needed
sure if you guys calculate those taxes
set those aside on a separate fund so
that when it comes to tax time you're
ready to pay for that and of course i'd
be working with the tax pro with your
situation you can connect with one over
at ramseysolutions.com they're they're
ramsay trusted they're going to help you
do things the ramsey way they've been
vetted by our team and they can help you
navigate what those tax implications
might be for your scenario but you guys
are crushing it man way to go yeah
awesome yeah this is this is good i like
this 40 000 bonus how do i how do i
manage it we like those calls so
incredible yeah that puts you in a great
financial spot yeah i love that all
right let's go to chad in indianapolis
indiana next chad how can we help
hey george hey ken honored to be on the
show here um have a quick question for
you with regards to
a potential business purchase
um so my wife and i are in baby steps
four five and six
uh we're putting back 15 percent for
retirement following the baby steps and
uh
my employer owns an insurance agency and
has given me the opportunity
to
become a potential owner in the future
here there are two other partners
involved really good friends of mine and
co-workers
um obviously there's a lot that goes
into any kind of a partnership i know
dave's not a big fan of that
um but my question is so
the the option is to go forward with a
structured buyout that would be
um
so
essentially we would
be
gradually buying out the agency until we
reached 10 ownership at which time we
would
uh become the full owners
right now my opportunity is 33 percent
partner
but the other two partners are open to
giving me majority
um
at which time i would have the yeah okay
the opportunity to be a majority owner
yeah couple quick questions we only got
about three minutes or so so we got to
get to the facts here
so how much is how much is that payment
uh is it monthly quarterly for you to
get to the 33 percent
so the payment for me would be about
1500 a month uh based on the valuation
we're at right now
um and that would be fifteen hundred
dollars a month from each partner in
order to reach that ten percent it would
take about five years to get there all
right that was my next question so take
you five years to get to where you would
own 33
now explain to me quickly how do you
then move from
33 percent to the other partners are
going to give you the majority what does
that look like
well so i
the the other partners would always be
part of the buyout
but i would have 34 so my payment would
just be a little bit higher than theirs
um and that's when the actual buyout
occurs i'd have 34 and they would both
have 33. so what does that give you over
having 33
as far as it just gives me uh more
control over the business i know that's
so you have kind of the majority voting
voting share you can get to make some
more okay that's what i wanted to know
is it do you have a little more power
and control in that spot so i'm doing
the math here fifteen hundred bucks a
month for five years you're looking at
ninety grand to buy into this thing
yeah it's actually a hundred grand so
it's just a little bit more than that so
i may have given you some so hundred
grand to buy in and what's the upside of
this
well so the upside is the the business
pulls in about 250 net profit at the end
of the year
um once i
formally purchased the business
then uh then we'd be looking at all that
upside coming in which i can then use to
pay off the remaining uh amount on the
business to the prior owners so 250 net
profit is that split between the three
it would be split between the three yeah
and that's on top of having a very
aggressive mindset and then you're
planning to pay them off this is gonna
take way too long it's not there's no
value it doesn't sound like it's gonna
be easy and it sounds like it could get
messy along the way yeah we let you
probably go a lot longer than dave wood
this is not a good idea this is this is
this is not uh this has got all kinds of
problems with it it's not spelled out
very clearly you got three people in the
pot uh this is not a very big business
either 250 000 net um these numbers just
don't add up to where this would be even
worth taking on all the headaches and
the risk that we are very clearly
against with partnerships yeah i if you
want to do this i'd go out on your own
100 you can do it now you could do it on
your own and have a lot more control and
i have to wait and hope and
deal with messy friendships i mean
that's the thing you might hurt some of
these friendships along the way is we
all fight for power and control over the
next few years yeah i mean the very word
control i mean it has to happen in these
conversations and that creates a weird
deal i think you do it on your own
either you buy it on your own
if you believe in it that much or you
start something on your own but this is
a bad move this isn't good financially
either
uh well good stuff hey fun times george
always thanks pleasure yeah i want to
thank our senior associate producer
kelly daniel and our erstwhile legendary
producer james childs and you america
thank you for listening this is your
show this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsay call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you